our bones are the scaffold that allows
us to cope with the strains of everyday
life but sadly accidents happen if our
phones do break they usually heal
normally but that's not always the case
in fact of the roughly 8 million
fractures reported in the u.s. each year
up to 10% won't heal properly if the
bone doesn't heal within the normal time
frame
doctors call these non-union fractures
and they drastically reduce a person's
quality of life to understand why
non-union fractures occur we first need
to understand how normal healing works
first ruptured vessels leak blood into
the void caused by the fracture and the
blood forms a clotted mass called a
hematoma
at this stage physicians try to ensure
that the bone is properly aligned and
fixed in place during the next two weeks
or so the hematoma is transformed into a
soft callus made of cartilage and
connective tissue tiny blood vessels
begin to work their way through this
matrix closely followed by bone making
cells called osteoblasts which reinforce
the callus eventually the soft callus is
transformed into hard bone and the
fracture is healed but sometimes this
normal healing process fails because the
blood supply gets cut off starving the
fracture sites of the specialized cells
needed for healing regenerative medicine
might give physicians a new way of
reconnecting the blood supply to the
fracture site scientists hope they can
kick-start the normal healing process by
encouraging new blood vessels to grow
into the gap to do this
researchers harvest the population of
the patient cells with a surface marker
called cd34 included in these cells are
endothelial progenitor cells or epcs
which promote the growth of new blood
vessels once isolated these cells are
infused into a gel which helps to keep
them in place at the fracture site then
a tiny bone graft is inserted into the
fracture sites along with the gel
providing a physical bridge between the
two fragments that contains all the cell
types needed for healing the e pcs
encourage new blood vessels to grow
and can also turn into the cells that
form blood vessels a large clinical
trial is underway in Japan to test
whether this cell therapy can boost the
healing process for patients with
non-union fractures and whether this
non-union can in fact have a happy
ending
you